Good morning, everyone.
I don't think I'll be needing my full time after the excellent review done by Dr. Martin
about the journey of Belentamab.
So I'll try to script through some of my slides here, here are my disclosures, and just the
outline of my talk.
I think I was going to cover some of the mechanisms and rebirth of Belentamab in multiple myeloma,
and also just do an across-trial comparison of where Belentamab stands compared to the
dominating world of bispecifics and CAR-T-cell therapy in myeloma, and then look at some
of the real world data, not just in myeloma, but also AL amyloidosis.
So just to highlight all the progress that's happening in the world of multiple myeloma,
I think every year or so we have a new therapy that's approved for treatment of patients
with multiple myeloma, and I think we are increasingly finding us in a place where we
have to find who are the right patients for this particular type of therapy.
And then I think this is a slide that I'll try to skip here because Dr. Martin covered
earlier on.
But I think this covers the journey of all.
The dream trials and they can assert the failures and successes of Belentamab and bringing it
to the FDA approval in 2025.
So thinking about the real world experience with Belentamab, these are some of the larger
studies that have been published in the past few years.
So these studies have included anywhere from like 30 to like close to 200 patients.
And the message is very clear that when Belentamab is used as a monotherapy, the real world outcomes
do match what we're seeing on the dream one and dream two trials.
We do see a little bit of under reporting of the popular toxicities in the real world
data compared to what we have seen in the clinical trial, but overall this data is very
similar to what was what we see in the clinical trial.
We saw with the dream one and dream two trial.
I think at this point of time, what we are missing is the real world evidence of Belentamab
combinations and we did have an EAP open for the last couple of years.
So maybe in the near future, we'll have some data that could actually come out from the
EAP and show that like, you know, the Belentamab combinations were equally successful compared
to how the trials were run.
Just another slide that I felt that, you know, was very important to bring out here as well,
which is like, you know, when dream seven and dream eight.
Results came out in 2024.
I think it was amazing that Belentamab held its place.
It showed that using Belentamab combinations increased deep responses like CRs in patients.
We saw MRD negativity in relapse, multiple myeloma patients, and we saw PFS and overall
survival benefit.
So I think in that year itself, like these were amazing results that showed like, yeah,
this is making a huge comeback and we are going to be increasingly finding us in a place
where we have to find like, you know, the right patient.
And the right approach to using all these drugs available.
But also like, you know, just recently we had the MAJESTIC-3 trial that was published
and we see when we look at the response rates, when we look at progression-free survival
curves out of the MAJESTIC-3 and CARTITUDE-4 trials, we can certainly point out which one
of the therapies are a true winner compared to the antibody drug conjugate.
And then I put this slide on because I was going to pivot over to AL amyloidosis, and
it is a competition.
It is a complicated space where like when it comes to treating patients who have relapsed
or have not responded to the initial therapy, it is a messy world to get any type of therapies
approved for patients.
And we generally scramble between all the different choices that have some trial data
published of like, you know, treatment in AL amyloidosis, but we always emphasize on
enrolling patients to clinical trials.
So just a few years ago, like Hans Mann, as well as Tufts, we came together to publish
this real world experience of valentamab in patients.
So we had patients with light chain amyloidosis, so we had six total patients where patients
got valentamab and they had exhausted all the other usual therapies.
And we saw that majority of these patients ended up responding to valentamab.
More than half of these patients had achieved a complete response.
And we saw cardiac responses in these patients who were treated with multiple prior lines
of therapy.
Similarly, the UK Amyloid Group also published like their experience of about 30 patients
where they showed that majority of the patients with AL amyloidosis were treated with valentamab.
And we see a similar toxicity profile between amyloidosis and myeloma where keratopathy is
basically the most common toxicity seen in these patients.
And we see some risk of infections that comes along with it.
And what was important to point out here out of the UK group was that in their 30 patients,
the time to next treatment was close to like two and a half years, which was amazing for
a time in this disease where we had no other therapies available.
And then.
Soon after that, we also had a phase two trial that was run in Europe.
It's the EMN 27 trial that also included around 30 patients who were treated with valentamab.
Valentamab was given every six weeks.
And we saw something similar to like what had been previously reported by us in the
real world experience that majority of the patients do respond to valentamab.
And we can see organ responses in these patients.
So just to think of like where things stand with light chain amyloidosis in the upfront
setting, there are cybordi is the clear cut winner.
We have had some trials.
We've had some trials in the past, but we can obviously point out like what's the winner
here when it comes to treating newly diagnosed patients.
But I think the future is coming where we will have other options come available, especially
some of the trials that are coming out.
There is a Bella cybordi trial that's coming out for newly diagnosed amyloidosis.
And there are some bispecific trials that are also coming out for newly diagnosed amyloidosis.
And I think if some of the real world, as well as like, you know, the early clinical
trial data that's available, it looks like, you know, when patients will get these types
of therapies, majority of them will have a hematologic response, whether that will
translate into an organ response or not.
I think that's something to be seen because a lot of times, even with very effective hematologic
therapy, like hematologic responses in our patients with the amyloidosis organ responses
are seldom seen.
And I think just to end with like, you know, where we are thinking of using the bispecifics,
the CAR-T cell therapy and the ADCs, I think it's certainly a challenge for us.
These are some of the options that are already available.
These are some of the options that are already in phase three clinical trials and are going
to be available in the next few years.
And then I think when it comes to making this choice, just to reiterate Dr. Martin's point,
that thinking of valentamab's role, like it'll be probably used for patients who have like,
you know, limitations to access like limitations in terms of like caregiver support, patients
who have a very high risk of infections, a profile like that might be a patient who will
be thinking of using valentamab.
And at the same time, I think like one of the uses we have found us increasingly like,
you know, consider in our patients is patients who have progressed after CAR-T cell therapy
and after Bispecific, we have a few patients at our center who have responded
to valentamab combinations to our surprise.
So we are putting together a case series to report that experience.
And with that, I would like to thank you all for hearing.